[Musique]
et combien de temps que d'habitude
et avant vous habitiez dans ce septième
enfin
asus palm beach fla
ça nous a changé parce que quitter le 7e
pour venir leur 17e et surtout à l'ats
beat d'or
fondation j'ai peut-être la goutte d'or
vous connaissez non
vous en avez entendu parler sûrement
moi aussi vaguement
c'est pour cela que j'ai choisi ce
quartier de paris
parce que justement je ne connaissais
pas
essayez de comprendre de connaître me
paraissait mieux qu'un constat prépare
une
aucune analyse définitive
avec l'aide de max mon assistant nous
avons essayé de percer les mystères de
la goutte d'or je dis bien un mystère
car devant une caméra personne n'est
vraiment en tic sa filiale disant que
j'avais eu de la boue dans un beau
quartier j'aime bien ça à près de 10 la
barbe et c'est dégueulasse il ya que des
rapports il ya des boules yahia il ya
bien des français qu'ils habitent yato
les générations tous se méfie et chacun
10 seulement les mots qui le défendent
qu'y at-il de cacher là dessous très peu
de français a voulu me répondre d autres
aussi d'ailleurs
le silence
les gens refusé d'être filmé
je me suis sentie voyeur
c'est pourtant très cousin de mon métier
de cinéaste mais devant toutes ces
portes fermées j'ai voulu un moment
baissé les bras et ne pas refaire le
fini
mais j'avais déjà fait un pacte avec
moi-même et jurée d'aller jusqu'au bout
quoi qu'il en soit dans ce quartier
cosmopolite et multiraciale on nous a
dit dans le quartier que la télévision
cinéma les journaux et tout ça exagéré
sur la goutte d'or alors dites-nous
pourquoi et comment ce pas qu'ils
exagèrent ce qui donne une image du
quartier suffisamment dégueulasse pour
que leurs projets immobiliers de
destruction soit légitime soit justifié
or ce projet de destruction du quartier
n'a aucune raison d'être aucune aucune
raison technique parce que les maisons
ici peuvent être réparés nous en avons
les preuves aucune raison sociale parce
qu'il existe ici les habitants qui ont
prouvé dans un livre d'or il y en a plus
de sens qui ont écrit chacun leur vie
ici est que et aucune raison pour
démolir ce quartier sauf des raisons
immobilière et ce à la mairie de paris
et l'état sont entièrement d'accord pour
le faire et c'est pour ça qu'on donne
cette image dégueulasse du quartier
comme quoi on peut pas y habiter etc et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on y laisse une
période qui pourrit le quartier et qui
est toléré par la police et par les
pouvoirs je le dis et j'assume ce que je
dis pas ce que je sais que c'est grave
c'est le samedi le dimanche qui a plus
de monde algériens tunisiens marocains
arrivés de toutes parts
province parfois de très loin pour
acheter parler du pays de la famille des
amis
ça réchauffe
et c'est pourquoi la plupart des gens
que l'on voit dans la rue de la goutte
d'or sont des gens qui ne font face et
seulement passer le reste on voit passer
depuis des mois des journalistes des
hommes de pouvoir des enquêteurs qui
vont dans les cours qui vont regarder et
tout ce qu'ils ont fait jusqu'à présent
tout contribue à nous démolir à détruire
nos vies à détruire notre vie de
quartier à détruire un des derniers
vieux quartiers de paris n'importe où
ailleurs dans paris en route après les
maisons mais ici on les retape pas
pourquoi parce que ce sont des pauvres
gens qui habitent et donc il faut les
raser pour faire un autre standing un
autre quartier de spéculations il ya une
spéculation taille médias parce qu'en
plus on l'a fait passer sous le couvert
du social ici c'est pas parce que c'est
du hlm pourra construire mais en fait ce
périmètre est très limitée et au delà on
va pouvoir restaurer la du louis
philippe à dix mille balles de mètres
carrés et ici on aura fait les barres de
béton et on aura démolit tout à
l'ensemble architectural remarquable
ici j'ai un texte qui a été signée par
des universitaires
monsieur huet bernard huet professeur
darchicourt tout cela oui comment
connaître la vérité les français de la
goutte d'or
m ce quartier ils le disent ils le
crient et dans les rues
il est très peu vu de france est
très peu pendant les jours et les jours
puis des nuits les nuits où je me suis
promené
alors pourquoi pourquoi dire aimer son
quartier ne pas s'y promener
cela m'a choqué un peu et c'est la
première fois que je n'ai pas compris et
ce n'était pas la dernière on n'a pas
besoin de protéger le patrimoine parce
qu'il faut [ __ ] dehors les habitants
voilà le point
ce que les jambes de l'extérieur pensent
d'eux
voilà qui sont aurait donc ouais
personnellement je n'ai pas trop de
contacts avec les gens de l'extérieur il
ya beaucoup d'immigrés ici mais les
immigrés les français ils vivent très
bien ensemble ici les habitants il ya
les preuves de sabah le livre d'or que
vous avez monsieur
désirons continuer à y vivre car nous
sommes beaucoup mieux ici ensemble que
dispersé au fond de banlieue anonyme le
som d'origines très diverses lieux
parisiens ayant toujours habité ici
maghrébins installés parfois depuis plus
de 30 ans antillais yougoslave africain
jeunes français arrivés ces dernières
années mais nous ne sentons habitants de
la goutte d'or et parisien les français
bien sûr je connais pas ma cassette vous
habite dans le quartier pendant qu'ils
habitent dans le quartier barbès
ils sont combien c'est le mélange de nos
cultures qui donne à notre quartier son
originalité sa richesse qui en fait un
lieu vivant dans la tradition du paris
populaire
aujourd'hui les pouvoirs publics veulent
détruire la moitié de nos immeubles et
chasser une grande partie d'entre nous
ont pressés combattre le
shérif mais on attend toujours la
plupart des immeubles qu'on projette de
détruire peuvent être réhabilités si les
normes qu'on veut appliquer aujourd'hui
à la goutte d'or l'était sur le 18e
arrondissement c'est une bonne partie de
la butte montmartre qu'il faudrait raser
il ya ici des gens qui sont là depuis
une famille depuis 1862 c'est donc la
quatrième génération et c'est une
personne qui habite au 36 rue de la
goutte d'or qui s'appelle mademoiselle
sénéchal et qui me parle du quartier il
ya la bille amène le boucher de la rue
de chartres il ya ici ipte athènes
monsieur d'athènes 84 boulevard de la
chapelle en france depuis 1923 boulevard
de la chapelle depuis 54 je suis
domicilié je suis complètement contre le
projet de démolition de mon
établissement toutes les normes sont
respectées
je suis un ancien combattant décoré de
la croix de guerre et c'est
pour me déménager je vous demanderai de
me tuer avant démolition
[Musique]
est ce que vous sentez en sécurité
ajouté
prenons pas
location n'est pas juste en sécurité on
capelle sortir enfin moi je sors pas
d'en partir on doit être accompagné
je m'adresse je mettais tout à l'heure
tu pouvais pas tout objet de rentrer les
bruiteurs
ouais franchement je suis obligée
d'entrer en victor je me pense
accompagner parce que sinon même quand
je passe à un bandage ont été agressés
fait valser pour passer
j'avais dans le ballet de trafic de
drogue oui mon champ gens voient
pratiquement tous les jours à chaque
moment de la journée là où j'habite il
ya une petite cour et dans la cour je
suis témoin de des trucs qui se passe
c'est ou alors ils en proposent aux
innocents demande d'appel l'herbe des
choses pareilles chez quoique non plus
concernés c'est chicago pour les gens
qui passent sur les gens qui habitent
pas c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
vous avez la drogue qui se vend sans
aucun problème et c'est un
vous avez des voleurs à la tire tout le
monde les connaît c'est toujours les
mêmes tout le monde le sait mais la
police tolère c'est un abcès de fixation
il la sphère ici parce que pourquoi si
les immigrés ne peuvent pas dormir la
nuit parce qu'il ya des jeu de bonneteau
et tout ça jusqu'à 3 heures du matin on
en a rien à [ __ ] 1,6 à la râpe
téléphone à la police monsieur il ya du
tapage nocturne ont eu rihanna ont mûri
à la figure c'est du racisme cette façon
là de donner c'est de laisser faire la
pègre ici on ne laissera le tolérerai
dans aucun quartier ne tolérerait ce qui
se passe ici et ça c'est au détriment
des habitants habitants français
immigrés tous ensemble parce que les
habitants sont déjà allés voir monsieur
jospin ensemble ils sont allés au
commissariat du 18e ils ont demandé des
comptes à la police rien zéro nul les
patrouilles de police de serrès saab
ratio ça vous
moi ça me rassure parfois mais parfois
eux mêmes
ils sont là ils sont très bien fait en
général sur
à chalon c'est à dire fait l'élite ainsi
plus d'un mais drogue touche à ça se
passe devant eux et disent rien mais
celles ci sont peut-être là mais
aujourd'hui ça va quand il faut voilà
c'est pas là au bon moment quand ça se
passe comme on y apprécie
on les appelle
ce n'est pas là si vous êtes arrivé tête
en grès
changement de pouvoir ici le fait que
jospin son arrivée n'a strictement rien
changé la police a continué la même
chose on a des preuves en quoi la police
ici ne fait rien et si elle ne fait rien
c'est pour les raisons bien précises
pour moi c'est le début du bulldozer de
chirac et chira et qu'il est ce parce
que l'état socialiste et monsieur chirac
sont parfaitement alliés sur le dos des
habitants un monde en crise déteint sur
tout et partout eh bien il a frappé ici
comme ailleurs non pas comme ailleurs
peut-être plus fort en quoi ces thèmes
couraient dans tous les sens on lui
avait volé tout son argent
je le regardais passer et repasser
courent en tous sens pleurant désespéré
j'étais muet me sentant unis kim
j'ai quand même demandé à mon caméraman
de le filmer
je crois que ce qui m'a choqué le plus
c'est que personne ne bougeait comme moi
impuissant il paraît qu ici c'est
courant il ne faut pas s'en étonner
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit c'est l'endroit
le plus le nom des endroits paris n'en
fait il là où le diable que des drogués
de prostituées mais en fait il a des
gens aussi puissant
général il ya aussi un rapport du préfet
de police que vous pouvez demander à la
préfecture sur la délinquance dans le
quartier
le taux de délinquance n'est pas plus
élevé qu'ailleurs mais çà mau qui
foutent le bordel c'est toujours la
poule ce qu'ils foutent le bordel je
n'ai pas peur de le dire bah voila je
n'ai pas peur de le dire ce qu'ils
foutent le bordel aussi à l'aise voilà
drapeau lui c'est inadmissible c'est un
scandale qui frappe
encore
les agents drogue il fallait toujours
ici c'est comme un long tronçon entre
deux ans par les sciences il en parle au
nom de l'entraidé ans par les crs c'est
pas de faire le monde le truc c'est la
brigade des stupéfiants d'être de faire
le nécessaire c'est pas eux par exemple
me demandez pas de guerre - des céréales
dans le bar qu'ils attendaient de
rentrer première des choses est en plus
un brigadier qu'il est rentré bourré
pour moi c'est le débat bien céder
rigolo je vais pas le dire qui n'ait pas
peur de le dire voilà c'est tout
il va chercher le concept est là bas
mais qui vient de casser les pieds ici
qu'ils aillent ailleurs là bas qui
valent au pire à la madeleine châtelet
mais c'est pas là bas s'il va pas
trouver les grosses têtes va chercher
les maquis qui vendent pour ce cas mais
le pauvre un bon sinon pas pour oublier
le chômage et pas de travail et l'autre
n'a pas de domicile a pas de c1 et
scandales qui voit ailleurs moi j'ai
rien à témoignage
je vais vous ligne je suis une femme
blonde blanche j'habite depuis trois ans
rue de la goutte d'or et je sortir seul
dans la rue et on a mis la main au cul
aux champs elysées boulevard saint
germain dans le métro ailleurs encore
une légende qui tombe tondu brigitte 55
rue de la goutte d'or j'aime bien le
quartier et je n'ai pas peur de le dire
vu barbès c'est donc c'est certain
[Musique]
et
je voulais commencer mon reportage en
tapant au jean pierre pierre bloch
conseiller municipal du xviiie
arrondissement me semblait le mieux
approprié pour parler d'un univers qu'il
connaît c'est semble-t-il parfaitement
bien la première fois que j'étais
candidat 73 et je suis inscrite et jeu
totalement effaré mais j'ai été pris par
ce quartier parce que je crois que je
quartier on aime on n'aime pas mais moi
j'aime ce quartier parce que c'est un
quartier vivant c'est un quartier devant
des réalités humaines faut savoir que ce
quartier quand on voit aujourd'hui ce
qui s'y passe c'est le quart monde à 10
minutes de tétouan tenez regardez sur
votre gauche vous avez les prostituées
voilà les délais les maisons les maisons
d'abattage charmer et vous avez des
prostituées qui sont là regardez
moi j'ai fermé les membres mais cette
année entre 78 et 80 voiliers à droite
et à gauche qui est fermé c'était des
bandas les ça aussi c'était des bordels
vous allez me raconter l'historique de
ses
37 c'est un bide dernier le bordel qui
était fermé il faut savoir que la rue de
la charbonnière était une rue plus que
chaud dans ce quartier il y avait ce
bordel y en avait 1 2 3 il ya des cinq
bambins dans la rue vous alors que les
fans à l'époque faisait entre 80 et 100
mon pass 1 jour bon nous on ne peut pas
très décent trempette et demandé aux
femmes six pages part que la
prostitution qui était l'aspect
difficulté en punition tu n'es de lyon
de marseille de bordeaux de toulouse et
qui dit mieux on produira en position
dans les bordels d'abord sur des bouts
de fer grandes entités tout à fait nous
en pareil donc ici en tant qu'élu à
l'époque je peux pas accepter ça et puis
ce n'est pas acceptable que dans paris
de l'abattage de plus sordide et exerce
donc jamais une bataille grâce aux mises
l'intérieur de l'époque christian bonnet
je menais une bataille pour fermer tous
ses bordels donc c'est une bataille
difficile parce qu'il y avait un talent
de tels intérêts convergents savoir que
le chiffre d'affaires estimatif à
l'époque était de 40 milliards de
centimes sur l'ensemble des modèles de
la goutte d'or combien de filles
travailleurs en moyenne il ya sur la
goutte d'or il y avait 800 filles qui
travaillaient et gilles faut savoir que
si c'était 24 heures sur 24 heures donc
c'était des trois fois éducation se peut
s'exprimer ainsi et que les six étaient
affichés voyez vous aviez des pancartes
comme ça 30 francs la femme affichez
vous l'aviez un souteneur à l'extérieur
et les gardes car c'est les aléas les
autres qui faisait la queue pour rentrer
à l'intérieur faut savoir que des filles
qui passé six mois à la goutte d'or
prenait 10 ans 15 ans d'âge parce que
120 passe par jour le week-end il faut
voir la qualité téléphone en paix avec
une complicité s'entassent tic une
lâcheté de tout le monde mais je ne suis
pas un lâche j'ai considéré que mon
devoir était de m'attaquer à ce problème
comme aujourd'hui mon devoir est de
m'attaquer la réhabilitation et
rénovation de ce quartier l'inca fermé
les bordels oui mais ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que bloc du temps il
était là il a fait retaper le 9 rue de
la goutte d'or et de 12 14 rue de la
charbonnière
aujourd'hui monsieur bloc est d'accord
pour démolir tout ce qui est autour
c'est fantastique non dans le plan de
réhabilitation du bol d'or il ya un
certain nombre 10 mètres qui vont tomber
parce que ça coûtera trop cher le bail
de l'habiter qui sont totalement pourri
et qui n'est pas question de pouvoir
refaire ces immeubles d'une manière
décente ce qu'on veut faire il est pas
question de virer
je dis bien de virer les habitants du
quartier vous avez des maghrébins qui
vit dans ceux qui vivent dans ce
quartier de plus plus de 20 ans ces gens
ont droit et c'est un devoir pour nous
de leur laisser la place dans ce
quartier parce qu'ils se disent y vivent
c'est leur quartier il n'est pas
question de mettre la porte mais toute
la fosse bataille c'est qu'il ya un
certain nombre de petits nombres qui ont
intérêt que le quartier soit comme il
est c'est à dire qu'on exploite un
certain nombre de gens qu'il soit pourri
parce que hier la prostitution
clandestine et les petits convives kara
drogue keira la revente de bijoux volés
la revente de n'importe quoi et que tout
le monde ya tout son compte ah ça on
attend qu'ils vont d'un contre nous les
voyous plus un certain nombre de bonnes
âmes qui sont propriétaires
d'appartements de studio totalement
dégueulasse mais qui sont ravis d'aider
des rentrées financières qui tiers de
ceux qui tirent de ces studios j'ai eu
du mal mais en fouillant bien j'ai
trouvé ce qu'on appelle les marchands de
sommeil s'il est pour toi 5.3
et oui pour 300 francs 20 mètres carrés
cela lui paraît normal après tout et
n'est pas la seule il n'y a pas qu'elle
dans ce quartier
mais des fois ils sont quatre à l'abri
voilà ces gens nous font la guerre bien
sûr ils ont pas vu qu'on démolisse bien
bien sûr ils veulent que ça continue et
puis vous avez une deuxième catégorie de
gens qui vous disent on veut démolir
mais quand vous les voyez apens on sait
très bien des policiers me virer tous
les arabes et les noirs ce quartier
pourquoi virer tous les arabes et les
noirs ce quartier qu'on va mettre à la
porte est-ce que jose molina
euh je pense pas non mais il ya une
bonne partie des molécules et et non
mais moi je pense pas parce qu'ils ont
aussi un problème
il ya des gens qu'ils ont des centres
merci et ça joue beaucoup sur la balance
économique
on s'inspire des jeux ne pas quitter et
de mon temps à des parents ces fours par
déjà mystique et n'ont jamais barbès /
labutta normalement ça
ça restera toujours parce que le démolir
sans démolir toute partie qui n'est ce
pas là c'est parce que c'est un rugby
le mot barbe est le bocuse d'or je
voudrais bien savoir
si une ranimons chef ce rapport explique
moi pourquoi la présence d'un fair est
il des patrouilles de police elle a
réussi
c'est à dire
y a t il eu beaucoup de plaintes
il ya beaucoup à faire défection se
folie
il
[Musique]
on va présenter certains mauvais signe
tandis que
la goutte d'or sa sphère de la drogue se
faire demain matin et pourquoi on dit
pas à
l'opéra ou bien à
l'opéra ou bien à saint lazare ou bien
dans les autres pourront dire que comme
moi j'étais content si ces journaux que
10 à mme sylvie aux accusations qui
s'amplifie en france il ya
[Applaudissements]
on a beaucoup parlé de drogue à la
goutte d'or c'est vrai
alors j'ai essayé d'en acheter et j'ai
réussi
et moi
250 000
à
gênés
elle est bonne
sordo ouais
donc chez moi en plus t'as pas confiance
cours
en plus de ce que
j'ai eu la plus grande peur de ma vie
quand le dealer que j'ai rencontré m'a
demandé de l'attendre
quand il est revenu au bout de 10 me
pour savoir si je n'étais pas flic il
m'a gentiment invités à consommer sur
place la dose d'héroïne
que je venais de lui acheter
au moins je voulais pas que tu veux non
malheureusement
bon allez salut mec tu peux te voir
quand tu joues tu viens au sziget en
hockey tout cela pour prouver qu'il y
avait en effet de l'héroïne à la goutte
d'or
mais on l'est déjà dit ailleurs aussi
gorge à goutte d'or non tranquille calme
rythmique son assistant nous avons
arpenté pendant ces nuits toutes les
rues de la rue marcadet au boulevard
barbès pas de signes étranges et par
rapport à notre quartier
sinon que tout était calme très calme
tout en remet profondément
le reportage explosif que j'imaginais de
faire me semble un pétard mouillé
est-ce que moi aussi je ne vais pas
bourrer le mou et que comme tous les
gens de l'extérieur
je ne mettais pas fait une fausse idée
du quartier
[Musique]
un ami acteur nous attend dès ce soir là
ils étaient là depuis deux heures
il nous raconte ce qui lui est arrivé ce
qu'elles peuvent pas s'y fier depuis que
je suis là entendra une heure mais je
n'a pas l'idée et les ja il me propose
de n'importe quoi le plus sûr c'est mon
pote ahmed il a écouté et wayne mw mon
pote écoutez est ce que ça ne vous dit
pas quelque chose je dis mais je
comprends pas je cherchais à des amis je
sais pas quand est-ce qu'ils vont venir
ouais mon pote loterie dit tu sais pas
parce que lui connaît pas les gâte
lehman à leur goût
non mon pote écoute ça te dis pas que
j'ai une américaine ici si tu votes
tu dis mais six prévenus deux femmes
l'autre ils m'appellent avait mangé une
française c'est pas cher ou bien une
sénégalaise tu veux
mais tout de suite ce soir d'être que je
demande quelqu'un bains où tu n'as pas
vu des gens avec des caméras je cherche
daniel duval mon poids toile ma fille de
sir encore ici mais exigeant est ici
complètement bouclé tout ce que tu
demandes à se sortir à leurs affiches ou
bien un truc de poudre ou bien que
propose du n'importe quoi si vous ne me
convenait pas trouvé de retrouver à sa
prime c'est pour ça justement puisque
ils m'ont trouvé que je suis très bien
sapé cette pensée pour ça ils ont pris
ce qu'ils ont fait ça
le il ya moins de deux ans je crois que
j'aurais à paris et au mois de novembre
à 2 ans qui suppose règle d'or d'abord
je pense que c'est très bien mais j'ai
peur la goutte d'or c'est démotivant tu
fais tu dis c'est très bien c'est très
bien parce que c'est présent bien je
pense bien que c'est le site us et c'est
le coeur même de paris une fois que la
douleur si tu veux elle a pu être
franchie de paris elle ne vit plus tiens
t'es tu te sens pas trop
la tnt ce pas un peu trop parce que toi
comme tu acteurs et tous ceux qui fument
du tabac pas trop reculer malgré eux
non je dis pas non non pas du tout au
contraire je mets saint affrique quand
je suis à la coupe d'or seulement quand
je viens à la cour d'or que je me trouve
en afrique
oui parce que soit ce que j'ai
l'habitude de faire en afrique quand
j'étais gosse quand je viens la goutte
d'or j'ai joué je retrouve ça oui mais
les gens avec les pièces à qui font ça
et puis joue toujours dans la petite
boutique que tu m'as dit
exactement alors si je trouve ce qu'on
appelle à
l'appliquer
c'est inclus que les africains utilisent
à la face de la france à damas et puis
la porte anti free
c'est le seul endroit à paris que j'ai
pu trouver
oui enfin je vivre à la goutte d'or si
les flics un décès des jeunes tranquille
un soir j'ai rencontré un voyou je lui
ai demandé de me décrire le quartier il
n'a parlé comme en morse
peut-être que mes questions pour lui
c'était peut-être aussi du mort ces
merveilles
mais ça doit je suis né et j'ai vu ses
origines j'ai vu moi je suis un gosse de
la rue moi je suis un peu à la rue moi
je suis pas du 16e 17e moi je me
contente du peu et toi si tu viens ici à
faire un repreneur pour quoi faire fissa
la rue je vais ainsi de compenser mais
ici on vous dit m ghetto tout ça est
harlem ça pas marché ça marchera jamais
parce que c'est pas un ghetto regarde
depuis tout à l'heure ils sont là est ce
qu'ils les ont égorgés
par jean-marc picard est de plus en plus
noir
c'est normal pourquoi parce que mes
tiroirs il est là pourquoi c'est un
meuble il 112,3 et parce que les noix
sont des antillaises fois non ils sont
français et que les arabes se prononça
voilà il faut savoir qu'au delà des
élections européennes il ya eu 20 % de
gens d'elkhart et ont voté le pen il ya
une espèce du profusion fantastique des
français et des
algériens des musulmans français parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de musulmans français
dans ce quartier bien certain nombre de
gens qui font la confusion complète en
dix ans et met chirac la police souvent
dans l'impact il faut savoir que
l'impact n'a pas de pouvoir police donc
si le maire de paris avait un pouvoir de
police on n'en serait pas là la police a
fait son métier elle arrête un certain
bojan qui remonte de la drogue elle
arrête les voyous
[Musique]
lorsque l'on ne connaît pas un endroit
et que tout ce qui s'y passe et
souterrains
le meilleur moyen je croise et les
forces de l'ordre
ont les accompagnants peut-être
là alors allons-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
des remises à
la soirée
je n'ai pas
[Musique]
rires 31 rue de me rejoindre dans
l'immeuble des appels au secours
la
rigueur
se
casser la gueule
alors d or d vous calmer tout ça
non décidément c'est comme ailleurs
les querelles entre voisins
tiens mais la patte africains ni du nord
plie du sud
[Musique]
m
pourquoi
[Musique]
quelqu'un en train de lire mon nouveau
scooter en bas de l'autre côté
d'une cour
dessin par la cour il va me coûte
pompiers démonter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas permise d'ailleurs c'est pas
permis tu frappes avec les mains
attachées c'est pas permis
gt rien fait il m'a frappé gratuite ou
pour quoi ça rime à quoi si tout simple
de dire voilà vous êtes en infraction
moi je me soumets
question actions je me souvenais je me
suis
je me suis mais je sais que je risque
pas grand chose pour consommation deux
chiffres ou d'herbe je sais que je
risque rien ça arrive à tout le monde de
fumer un joint ça arrive à tout le monde
mais où il ça arrive à tout le monde
parle et pau en moi j'ai mon professeur
de maths c'est un professeur de docteur
en mathématiques en ce1 professeur
mondialement connu la première chose
qu'il fait qu'on tisse rêves et ses
films et une pipe de sites pure tu vois
tu connais pas ta pas les moyens de le
connaître de problème on n'a pas les
moyens dont la tête de le connaître si
t'as même pas les moyens dans la tête de
me suivre moi je peux te donner des
cours de tout ce que tu veux sur
monsieur dr
docteur en physique oui docteur en
physique oui oui ça paraît petit gaucher
qui peut laisser deviner c'est illogique
peu illogique pour toi preview donc
appelé ce somptueux les uns être mais
derrière la justice ne suit pas quand on
dit justice ne suit pas où il va y avoir
un certain nombre de gens qui vont
commencer à hurler en dix ans créée au
fascisme en dix ans et de logistique
urinaire ses devanciers nos réalités
dans ce quartier de la sécurité il n'est
pas tolérable aujourd'hui de voir dans
ce quartier on tue on agresse des gens
du troisième âge on viole
ce qu'il est parti
[Applaudissements]
longtemps
cependant deux euros
mais c'est quand le café que ça s'est
passé l'un cette liste et viols devant
bon allez montez dans le temps on va
vous emmener à l'hôpital tout m'est pas
venu la voir si vous voulez des visites
pour la montée ou est-ce qu'il est brun
demeurer loin malgré tout voir boire va
d'abord sont ni ta main
va monter dans le coeur revoir
bon on va
j'ai le moral à zéro
c'est une amie l'état rien ne s'est
passé
max partie enquête revient lui aussi
désemparé
tour est extrêmement hermétique et
impossible à la réalisation d'un
reportage traditionnelle et
faut pourtant continuer puisque en
vacances on s'était juré max et moi
d'aller au fond des choses et qui devait
faire comprendre c'était notre but
alors peut-être en insistant un peu au
dessus du bistrot
je sens qui peut
et des types qui
rawdon
est ce que c'est les mecs
soit je me suis dit hier soir touche à
sa fin
[Musique]
attention pas
pas
[Applaudissements]
je sens quelques
coopérant soir
chaud
alors très curieux
kawashima
m
donc au bout des débats
[Musique]
par ailleurs
nous
[Musique]
mehdi un jeune algérien qui connaissait
la goutte d'or a bien voulu me parler
très gentiment
mais comme les autres détourné
volontairement les questions trop bas à
ici on ne peut pas parler ici n'a rien à
dire
cette nuit là j'ai rencontré d'autres
types que je n'avais jamais vu des
militants politiques
me parler de l'algérie de l'algérie
police
après quelques palabres qui acceptèrent
de profil mais qui pourtant risc group
est le mec qui passe tout de suite
derrière les mecs le mec à chadli
les mecs à chaque poste de l'aide
militaire la sécurité militaire
l'amicale
je veux dire en france ça ça devient
l'amicale tu vas les comités
pour hisser
[Applaudissements]
au nom de la démocratie chez nous et on
voulons nous voulons que tous les
algériens reviennent
en algérie d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'ils
font ça c'est gouvernement nous ça prend
ça à émigrer luttons ensemble contre le
racisme
c'est un racisme ça n'existe pas
toujours ça fait cinquante deux ans que
ça existe et pour le droit à la
différence nous on veut pas de
différence non on veut rentrer chez nous
on veut pas concurrence avec les
français on veut rentrer chez nous c'est
tout c'est ma longue ainsi à barbès
parce que
ici viennent du nord ils viennent de
toutes les grandes banlieues viennent de
tout
barbey 6,6 et c'est orange et lg ou
s'ils lui prévenu que personne ne
parlerait parce que les commerces bas
prix doivent eux aussi mon bac m'en
parler de spéculation
mais eux comme les autres des
explications n'étaient pas très
difficile
militants principalement je dirais même
uniquement
c'est autre chose
voilà
on habitait ici
à chacun se plaît bien
[Musique]
oui
kim et ken
j'ai tout entendu
peut-être singstar des il ne fait pas
confiance on n'est même pas
ceux qui sont terrorisés oui y'a un
featuring faut savoir que ce quartier a
toujours été un quartier d'accueil où
traditionnellement depuis alors la gamme
des entrées de biens en tout 14 89 44
vous êtes toujours une terre d'accueil
pour les et les gens qui venaient du
monde est déjà utilisé et non la guerre
d'algérie je crois qu'il y ait une
cassure entre la population française
des aberrations et mener parce que bon
c'est un quartier dur où il ya eu non on
prend un peu plus loin mais là on va on
va tomber sur la rue marcadet au haut
lieu de la vente de drogue et s'estime
menacé un croyant ça se passe au vu si
vous regardez les jeunes sont venus
acheter c'est dramatique mais un dessin
un dessin le monde ici je sais nautique
d'impôts et à droite donc au moment de
la gare et de jurys et la cassure entre
la population française et la beauté de
la surélever puisque la guerre d'algérie
est c'est fait aussi la règle d'or c'est
un des seuls quartiers de paris dont
l'un des rares cartes et paris il y
avait des harkis et le soir vous aviez
des patrouilleurs qu'il ya eu une
bataille fantastique d'abord entre le
mnr et leurs feux led et après entre le
fn et la police française et les arts
qui donc est une une cassure parce que
ce quartier l'équité toujours paisible
éclats il y avait des batailles rangées
il y avait tous les soirs on ramassait
tout au tout les jours tous les matins
on ramassait des délais type assassiné
il ya eu les réseaux du fln qui se sont
organisés compte totalement racketter
les commerçants musulmans il y avait un
certain nombre de maisons de passe à
l'époque qui étaient des ressources pour
le hlm c'est qu'à l'époque soit sûrement
la guerre d'algérie se disent 57 58 59
68 commandes dépendance après
l'indépendance d'algérie ce quartier
votre venue plus ou moins calme mais
c'est devenu aussi un quartier deux
autres prostitution
[Applaudissements]
non merci
prochaine fois quand je ne pas oublier
vos papiers
[Applaudissements]
mais pourquoi
[Musique]
il faut savoir que ce quartier une
tradition maya donne que les clients des
commerces magasins des restaurants
maghrébins et que les gens viennent de
100 à 150 km au nord de paris pour faire
leurs courses parce qu'ils trouvent des
commerces moins cher retrouve des
couleurs pour lui régionaux et qu'ici
peut acheter un sapin de choses qui
n'ont pas qu'il ne peut pas se
ressemblent ils se retrouvent c'est le
point de rencontre quand elle qui
travaille à lille ou à je ne sais pas
quelle est à 100 km de paris revient ici
c'est qui peut aller dans la boue d'or
va retrouver un ami va retrouver un
copain ne va pas être perdue au milieu
de paris donc c'est un point de
rencontre le démon et ben
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon échec
j'avais refusé d'y aller avec un caméra
la liberté de chacun
malgré ma bonne volonté de faire
comprendre aimez l'univers de cacher
facilement de la goutte d'or
comment alors aboutir
il me reste une année record banal jorgo
film et le folklore autres en sus
[Musique]
à
me poser des questions sur eux surtout
sur la nuit
[Musique]
je vais atteindre ryan avait rapporté
que la voulez puis à talavera
milieu
ma vie rires
dorrans bernal j applaudis semblait les
mouches qui se passe quand ils font la
musique en savoie
bref l'ambiance et tout ça parce que le
milieu français à face à des gens il
vient c'est fait c'est pas pour voir si
pour recevoir du par une grippe a ils
travaillent pas et des problème à l'est
il ya aussi des gens qu'ils étaient des
gens autant en tant qu'algérien et tous
à tous les marocains sans écouter marc
anthony tunisie par un technicien réseau
mais aussi des citoyens notamment à
sinsheim
là où il été assassiné à faire deux fois
ils ont mis un certain jeudi son ebe
très près très près very big pas et puis
pas y aller en discothèque vie sauvage
c'est une discothèque il n'est pas de ce
milieu réveilla mail nartelle faisaient
rien enragé ferait bien d'arrêter les
voulais pas lui l'ouvragé vous l'avez
vous verrez à gérard eychenne chez moi
j'ai rendez vous le dire ou le sait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
coc
pour accepter qu'ils passent devant la
caméra
j'ai discuté 3h15 caisse
puis on s'est mis d'accord sur un point
[Musique]
on
oh
ils ont
pour les a filmés pendant une heure
comme convenu
après le patron vise à jeter dehors
je me disais que mon film était finie et
que je n'avais pas compris grand chose
j'étais persuadé maintenant que tout
avait été grossis enflé défiguré et que
mon choix sur ce reportage était une
erreur
où était la violence
ici plus qu'ailleurs
pourtant cette violence suspendu comme
par un fil
a fini cette nuit-là par me tomber
dessus
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suivent les appels de tanus appel au
public
[Musique]
il ira en reportage d'arrivée cinq
minutes après un meurtre c'était bien
pour le film mais il m'était difficile
de m'en réjouir
bien plus tarder
[Musique]
un habitué des quartiers qui buvait un
verre tranquillement au bas comme tous
les soirs une querelle entre deux
joueurs de cartes
il veut les séparer un des joueurs sur
son revolver il ne finira jamais son et
lumière
que c'est arrivé je suis un peu bourré
et ben ammar qui m'insultent tous ma
famille moi j'étais un fix ibal à la fin
j'ai tiré sur un autre qui m'a empêché
ses pattes et à tout seul voilà c'est
pas exprès je la fais à l'améliorer si
ça me fait mal au coeur mais je suis
certain que ça arrive ça arrive
voilà
je me rendais tous elle je la fais le
congrès ben je me rendis tout seul chez
le patio la mairie
ce n'est pas pour moi le mélange
multiraciales qui fait le danger de ce
genre de quartier mais la concentration
d'individus refermer sur eux mêmes avec
leurs peurs des angoisses de ceux qui
les entourent et qui les regardent
souvent injustement parce qu'ils ne sont
pas d'ici qu'ils sont comme ça
parce que plus parce que moins que nous
et demain
c'était ma dernière nuit à la goutte
d'or
[Musique]
post scriptum
d'une lettre écrite au premier ministre
le 16 septembre
1984 jean pierre pierre bloch déclarent
les habitants de la goutte d'or s'estime
aujourd'hui en état de légitime défense
[Musique]